[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ما عندي خولي موسم الصيف يهجر الباديه
هالصحراء الى موارد المياه وينتقل الحاضره
الى مزارعهم ويسمونها بالمقيض وهو المكان
الذي يستقرون فيه طوال موسم القير وينتقل
اصحاب المناطق التهاميه ذات الحراره
العاليه والرطوبه الخانقه الى الاماكن
المرتفعه البارده ليش يزينون كذا لانه مع
دخول جمره الغيظ يونيو ويوليو اغسطس ترتفع
فيها درجات الحراره الى معدلاتها العاليه
وتصل فيها رمز الارض الى غايته وتهب فيه
رياح السموم الحاره وهذا التنقل والارتحال
يصنع لنا النسيج الاجتماعي ويثير الاحاسيس
الحبيه وهذا ما جعل العرب يتميزون في وصف
حبهم حظيت يا عود الاراكي بثغرها اما خفت
يا عود الاراكي اراك لو كنت من اهل القتال
قتلتك ما فاز مني يا سواك سواك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وبعد اربعين يوما تقريبا تبدا درجات
الحراره بالاشتداد بما يسمى عند العامه
ابتدت
الجوز الاوله والجوز الثاني ذبحت القير
ومدتها 26 يوما المرزم والتليبين جمره
القيظ ومدتها 26 يوما وحين ذاك تبدا درجات
الحراره بالانفراج التدريجي ضاقت فلما
استحكمت حلقاتها فردت وكنت اظنها
لا تفرج
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]